four years ago I started working on a
game engine now it's time to get serious
and release our first game on Steam a
game heavily based on a massively
successful classic which had a Brand New
Concept that took the World by storm
stick around to learn what it is how it
works and how you can add it to your
game
my games in the 70s such an important
time in the video games industry with
games like pong which by the way was the
first commercially successful video game
what else was their breakout asteroids
and of course Space Invaders now Space
Invaders was a particularly important
game it was released in 1978 and it
became the number one game worldwide
like in the history of video games it
started off as a hit in Japan and then
it just grew worldwide they literally
had arcades open up which just had Space
Invaders it turned video games into a
global industry and it also started the
Golden Age of arcade games so
what made the game so good such a crazy
difference between games nowadays and
back then and yet Space Invaders still
turned up two billion dollars in
quarters that's not inflation adjusted
two billion dollars in quarters in
actual quarters why would people keep
playing it I mean look here's a clip of
the original Space Invaders
[Music]
does that look fun to you I can't really
say no can you I mean it's a classic
right but what about this what about
this what if we just
remove this little thing just uh sweep
it under the rug okay cool shooting
aliens still kind of fun yeah not bad
and then when you lose it just says game
over and then you can play again
would you
would you really yeah yeah I'd play I'd
play again wait
what's this I have to pay
to play again didn't know EA was a thing
back then huh yeah I uh I I guess I have
one quarter left and I'm already all the
way here in the arcade I might as well
play again but hang on what if we just
put this back here hmm that's
interesting
to number and it's it's going up
exciting and then when you lose you get
your score oh wait a minute who's this
what's this your arch nemesis and why is
my score lower than his where's that
other quarter you're damn right I'm
gonna play again point being by simply
adding an increasing number on the
screen and showing it to you in a
leaderboard when you lose you now had so
much more reason to play the game again
and again
and again Space Invaders was the first
game to feature leaderboards I mean
think about how cool that was for the
first time to have a leaderboard gaming
suddenly became so much more social and
competitive you'd race to the arcade
after school first thing to try and beat
your friends or even become king of the
arcade also I hear I was born in uh 94
so
I never knew the good old days this
obviously generated so much money for
the arcades and the games industry as a
whole just pushed it to completely new
levels so anyway I guess what that means
is that our game definitely needs
leaderboards but we're not exactly
making our game for an arcade are we
well if you think about it isn't the
whole world just one big arcano
okay fine whatever was I connected these
days without internet but now instead of
being King of the arcade you could be
king of the entire world
so we need a global leaderboard
but
how do we set that up exactly well the
concept is actually really simple you
play the game you lose you submit your
high score this has to go into
the internet where it will reach a
server and be stored in a database along
with everyone else's score now when you
want to view the leaderboards either
in-game or on the web This Server reads
this course from the database and serves
you the data so how do we set that up
for our game well we need a server
just call hosting
what a great idea
uh yeah hello hostinger uh yeah one
server please
okay cool thank you
I hope that comes quick because I need
to get this done today
so now that we have our hosting and
server let's set it up this part is
super easy one of the reasons why I love
hosting her now we specifically need a
VPS here because we'll basically just be
using it as a computer all we have to do
is go through this series of pages
filling in just some details just some
standard details that you'll need for
your server pick a server location
usually I go with wherever most of my
users are going to be we can pick from a
wide range of operating systems I'm just
going to go with Ubuntu 20 set a root
password of course and yeah that that's
it our server is ready to go now did I
mention that hosting I have some
absolutely amazing Black Friday deals
you can get up to 80 off web hosting and
if you use coupon code Cherno at
checkout you'll get an additional 10 off
just go to hosting.com and check it out
for yourself it's seriously so cheap
right now and I also want to thank
hostinger for being such an amazing
partner and sponsor of this video
alright so
now that we have the server all set up
ready to go we can ssh in everything is
working it's time to do some web
developments which
personally I hate or or
we get Tim to do it basically this is
the plan and how it works once someone
loses the game and they want to submit
their high score we can use an HTTP post
request to send any data we want from
our game onto the web server so for
example we'd need to send like the name
of the player and their high score at a
minimum and then on the server side
which will receive that post request it
can process it and it can take the data
from the post request like the player's
name and their score and store it in the
database just like in our beautiful plan
now we use node.js to make this happen
but you could use any like server-side
programming language such as PHP in fact
if you use PHP it'd be very simple
probably just like a few lines of code
and then of course from the viewing of
the leaderboards side of things all you
really need to do is ask the server for
some scores and then it can provide that
to you in the form of like a Json string
and you can of course have your game
pause the Json and present it in some
kind of nice way and basically do the
same thing inside a web browser if you
want your leaderboards to be viewable on
the web and yeah that's it that's pretty
much all there is to it great we can
ship our game now
what's this someone's trying to hack us
whenever there's a connection to the
outside world there's always that one
guy
that one guy who just has to ruin
everything we need some security
otherwise all it really takes is someone
just popping open cheat engine while
playing our game modifying their high
score adding some zeros or something and
then just submitting it and the server's
like oh well I guess that's your high
score well done you're number one now in
the whole world it's really as simple as
that but you could go even deeper and
more advanced like you could decompile
the binary of the game modify some
things submit something way larger or
even intercept the post request in
something like Wireshark and then just
modify the data packets or just hit the
server yourself from your own
application with your own post request
with a high score
and the server is just not gonna know
any better now technically speaking
this is a bit of a hard problem to solve
I mean look at pretty much any game
nowadays they have cheaters to some
extent and they can't really fully fix
it did you hear that Call of Duty Modern
Warfare 2 the second Modern Warfare 2 is
actually getting people to like verify
their phone numbers before you can play
online but that kind of illustrates just
how difficult this problem is to solve
so there really is not a quick easy fix
but but we can do a number of things to
make cheating way harder than just
popping open cheat engine for example we
should use https instead of just HTTP
because what https will do for us is it
will actually encrypt like the contents
of the packet so it won't make it it
won't make it easy for someone to just
open up wiresharks see exactly what the
price request should look like and then
Spruce it themselves and also how about
validating the scores like server side
you'd get a really high score that's
unusually high don't immediately display
it and publish it onto the leaderboards
maybe hold that bad boy for moderation
but speaking of moderation how do we
even know if a score like that is
possible well why don't we collect some
other metrics from the game such as how
long that round or match lasted for how
many kills they got how many bullets
they fired because if someone's cheating
in a very obvious way like they've
they've fired five bullets and their
score is 5 billion something is wrong
here they've definitely cheated it's
just physically impossible to get that
high score by just firing five bullets
and
in case we get a naughty boy let's also
collect people's IP addresses with
consent of course and also if the game
is on Steam for example their steam IDs
so that we can ban them we can just hold
a Blacklist on the server of certain IP
addresses or usernames or IDs or
whatever and just reject those scores
and worst case scenario Manual High
Score approval the nuclear option
basically what that means is that
whenever someone serves a high score
it doesn't show up on the leaderboards
until someone from your development team
goes through the list goes through the
queue and gives it gives it the tick of
approval now technically at this stage
we're reaching territory where first of
all like that would be really difficult
to do if your game is popular and you
have a lot of high scores but also you
know if someone cheats drastically like
their score is like several orders of
magnitude above the next person like
yeah it's easy to see that they're a
cheater don't display their score but
what if someone has just cheated enough
to be like in the top 10 worldwide
they're not really in the top 10 but
their score appears as though it is in
the top 10. we could use those other
parameters I talked about such as like
kills time played bullets shot that kind
of stuff to attempt to kind of humanly
validate or even using an algorithm
validate whether or not that's a
possible score but at this rate it's
kind of like speedrunning if you want to
submit your speed run you need video
evidence and even speedruns have
cheaters and these anti shape measures
all they're really trying to do is just
not display the score in the
leaderboards the score can still exist
in the database we can still have a
record of that person in there massive
cheating but if it doesn't show up in
the leaderboard then their cheating
doesn't matter we can't really 100 stop
this so the best we can do is just try
and make this as hard as possible
because at the end of the day the real
losers are the people spending hours
trying to break the game instead of
being a normal person and just enjoying
it that's it hope you guys enjoyed this
video don't forget to check out hosting
on while they have their Black Friday
sale link below and look out for our new
game coming soon